The International Classification
of Disease is the oldest data
standard dating back to the 1800s.
And in a sense, even to earlier
centuries when researchers first became
interested in the causes
of human mortality.
Traditionally, it's been a list or
classification of medical diagnoses.
It's maintained by the World Health
Organization, and is updated every ten
years, with the latest version being
ICD-10, which was adopted in 1994.
Here in the US, where still using ICD-9,
even though most other countries,
are using 10.
ICD-10 is a major expansion capable of
representing many more clinical details.
We can see that, here, by comparing
the coding systems' capabilities for
breast cancer.
In ICD-9, we know what portion
of the breast is involved.
The central portion, here, but
we don't know which breast.
In ICD-10, we not only know which
portion of the breast is involved,
but we know whether it's the right or
the left breast.
So in ICD-10, laterality is represented,
which greatly increases the number
of codes, which is a big part of the
objections to using it here in the U.S..
In fact, ICD-10 really becomes
an ontology capable of
representing clinical relationships.
Here, we can see that
the patient has gout, affecting
their left shoulder.
But they have not yet
developed a uric acid deposit,
called a tophus, in that shoulder.
We can also see that the etiology,
or the reason for
their gout, is kidney failure.
The current U.S. target date for
ICD-10 adoption is October 1st, 2015.
But given how close we are to ICD-11,
there are some proposals
to skip ICD-10 entirely.